I woke up to a couple of early modern
calls I'm missed on my mobile and it was
the broad police
hundreds of miles from Westminster
politics and power exist away from the
glare of the national Spotlight I was
frustrated this man ran Labor's local
election campaign in the Northeast town
of redcar just over a week before
polling day fraud police arrived on his
doorstep and said they were
investigating his campaign leaflets two
plain clothes policemen came into my
front room I was sat down I did feel a
little bit and paused on customer you
know that was stood up I did feel
interrogated slightly
that visit and police visits to the
homes of two other labor activists
triggered by this man Steve Turner Not
only was he their rival Tory election
candidate he is also the police and
crime commissioner for this area it's an
excellent job really enjoying it
um it's everything I expected to be and
more a job that means he oversees the
very officers investigating his
opponents following his complaints
on Tuesday he failed to get elected as a
counselor losing in a third recount to
the same labor activists that were
investigated Steve Turner told Sky News
he complained to the council about this
labor leaflet and that it was standard
for the complaint to be passed to the
police
fraud officers told one of the activists
that they were there because the leaflet
had upset Steve and no action would be
taken but Mr Turner told us that he did
not direct the police response Cleveland
Police said that the inquiries were
routine his wife also standing
unsuccessfully in the same ward defended
his conduct my husband was a candidate
in this race and he has every right the
same as any other member of the public
to report offenses to the police
you don't think that there is an evident
conflict of interest involving the
police getting the council to involve
the police in a race in which he is
involved I do not know if it was a
conflict of interest that would mean
that I would never be able to report any
crime that was happening to me as an
individual on his on his Facebook page
he said that the police agreed that
there was disinformation how did he come
to that judgment
no comment
what's striking is the scale of
involvement from Cleveland Police three
separate visits to three different labor
party members even though the police are
quite upfront with them there was no
offense committed and then they phoned
Tory Steve Turner with a readout of what
went on could this have anything to do
with the Tory candidate also having
oversight of the people in the building
behind me
Sky News has discovered a second
political opponent of Steve Turner was
investigated by police after Turner made
a harassment complaint via the local 101
hotline
police told the individual there was no
case to answer
some claimed Turner's Behavior could
amount to an abuse of power the
perception is that he abused his power
in this case he you know nobody else
would have got the level of attention
that the police gave him and this
allegation uh that he got and that
clearly demonstrates that he had the
power to make it happen whereas you and
I wouldn't have would never have been
able to do that this episode revealed by
a quirk a focus on redcar as the final
election result to declare does sunlight
shine often enough in all parts of our
democracy
Sam coat Sky News red car